الذي جعل من هذا التاريخ حلب للصراع والشد
والجد الذي جعل من هذا التاريخ بدلا من ان
يكون فعلا مصدر للاثراء والجمال والتلاحم
والترابط هو فعلا هذه الخطابات
الايدولوجيه المتطرفه الجماعات الاصوليه
الجماعات الارهابيه جماعات الاسلام
السياسي التي ارادت فعلا ان تقوم باختطاف
التاريخ الاسلامي ارادت ان تقوم باختطاف
التاريخ الاسلامي لصالحها كيف فعلت ذلك هي
قامت صورت لنا التاريخ الاسلامي انه عباره
عن حاله حرب بين المسلمين والكفار حاله
حرب بين المسلمين والكفار طول الوقت وان
هذا التاريخ هو عباره عن تاريخ عسكري
وصراع ديني وهذا غير صحيح ابدا تاريخ
المسلمين والتاريخ العربي والاسلامي هو
ليس صراع بين المسلمين والكفار
وابرز مثال على ذلك يسقط هذه الشائعه هو
ان حينما تعود الى المدن والعواصم في
تاريخ الحضاره الاسلاميه في الدوله
الامويه والعباسيه ومن بعدهم مثلا بغداد
ودمشق قرطبه سمرقند وغيرها الغالبيه
العظمى من سكان هذه هم من غير المسلمين من
الطوائف الاخرى من غير المسلمين هم يعيشون
ويتعايشون داخل هذه المدن الاسلاميه بل
ابعد من ذلك يعبرون ويحتفلون بطقوسهم
وشعائرهم الدينيه والعقائديه في العلن بل
تذكر يعني يذكر الصخر في كتابه المسالك
والممالك ان في مدينه الرها في العصر
العباسي قرابه 300 كنيسه تخيل هذا الرقم
اذا كان تاريخنا عباره عن صراع بين
المسلمين والكفار كيف يمكن ان يحدث هذا
الامر كيف يمكن ان تكون مثل هذا التنوع
الحضاري والتعايش الديني